what is it about a guy like tom brady
that makes him so
capable to pull it off yeah over time do
you notice it like do you
i mean i think it probably goes back to
his work at work ethic like this start
and then
you know he was he was in a great
situation yeah i mean i think you know
timing
situation work ethic um you know his
talent his brain like
a lot of things have to come together
like if you look at really successful
people um
you know they're they're obviously
talented in whatever their field is but
there's there's got to be some things
that come together to help them get to
this point yeah a team like uh just uh
yeah and i mean being with bill and josh
mcdaniels and their defense was
unbelievable when he first got there and
obviously he was good too and he grew
with that and he became the team but
you know you look at a lot of these
quarterbacks that get into the league
early and they're just they're you know
they're on bad teams they don't have a
lot of talent around them um the coaches
coaches kind of may be getting fired or
coming in and starting over so
and not to take away from tom because i
mean what he's done is it will probably
never be done again um you know but he
would he came into a really really good
situation and and to his credit he he
took advantage of it you know better
than anybody could
is there like anything that he possesses
does it seem like he's magic when you're
around like when you see him or
something or is it just
well he's he's aging backwards right
yeah it is pretty pretty magnificent i
mean i think it is yeah i mean he's
benjamin button
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you